[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy vengo a hablarles de las lechugas
y me gustaría que me ayuden un poco
a entender cómo son las lechugas como
son la lechuga
ricas verdes
frescas
saludables sanas donde nacen las
lechugas
en la tierra excepto en un árbol rafa el
árbol no la tierra es cierto
hacia donde apuntan las hojas de la
lechuga si el viento está para hallar
las hojas de lechuga están hacia allá si
el viento está hacia el otro lado las
las hojas de la lechuga
apuntan hacia el otro lado donde termina
una lechuga por lo menos para lo que lo
ocupamos nosotros como ser humano en una
rica ensalada cierto en un sandwich más
rico todavía otros quito falta tomate
mayo lechuga bien
pero también las lechugas puede terminar
podrían un refrigerador también la
lechuga puede terminar en el camión del
verdulero que nunca saco que se pudrió
ahí y murió ahí también la lechuga puede
terminar en un cajón
y la primera invitación que quiero
hacerles aquí es aquí por favor no sean
unas lechugas y les voy a explicar por
qué
porque nosotros queremos gente joven
nosotros queremos una ciudadanía que sea
arquitecto y constructor de su propio
futuro que esté dispuesto a jugársela
que esté dispuesto a atreverse que
entiende y conozca el concepto de que
equivocarse no es tan malo hoy día el
que se equivoca el que se equivoca el
tonto es malo feo cochino todo lo que el
que se equivoca tiene todo lo malo
cierto pero no nos damos cuenta que el
que se equivoca es una persona que se
atrevió como dice el título de esta
charla barreras y oportunidades también
barrera hay muchas y cuesta salir
adelante pero hay muchas más
oportunidades y sin duda que se puede lo
importante es atreverse
lo importante es jugársela cuando yo
tengo un proyecto en el que creo cuando
yo tengo un proyecto que tiene un
propósito movilizador que ya vamos a
contar más adelante de qué se trata
tengo que atreverme y jugármela incluso
hacer cosas distintas
albert eisntein definida la locura como
hacer varias veces lo mismo esperando un
resultado distinto y ahí tenemos la
lechuga que es lo que yo no creo que
ustedes sean
además quiero contarles si conocen este
señor
seguramente no samuel pierpont langley
lo conocen han escuchado una vez es
improbable que no es amor por langley
inventor físico de la segunda mitad de
1800 estadounidense
estaba en la carrera por construir el
primer avión pilotado del mundo
profesional un gran físico
no que tenía un gran físico era un era
un profesional muy destacado en la
materia
contaba con el apoyo del instituto
smithsonian
y contaba con el apoyo y el
financiamiento del departamento de
defensa de los eeuu
en otra parte eeuu carolina del norte
había dos hermanos
a estos se los pueden ubicar all over y
wilbur wright
que no tenían nada de lo que nosotros
podemos llamar que es la clave del éxito
no eran profesionales no tenían
financiamiento y ninguno del equipo que
los acompañaba era profesional pero
tenían algo tenían algo que les hacía o
los invitaba a salir adelante tenían un
propósito y un propósito movilizador
yo creo que estamos langley no operaba
con un propósito movilizador podría
pensar que buscaba otra cosa
cuando un 17 de diciembre de 1903 el
flyer one se eleva
por 12 segundos y 37 metros
bajo el pilotaje de orville wright
es no solamente
un avance en la aviación no solamente
empieza a cambiar la historia empieza a
cambiar el futuro empieza a cambiar la
forma en cómo nosotros nos relacionamos
como nosotros nos comportamos sino que
también es una clase magistral y
fundamental de propósito del por qué
hacemos lo que hacemos cuando el
propósito es débil cuando no tenemos
algo que hace que se nos apriete la
guata cuando no hay algo fundamental no
hay algo potente que hace que no nos
levantemos de la cama que estemos
dispuestos a arriesgarnos que estemos
dispuesto a juzgarnos es bien probable
que a la primera dificultad
nosotros tenemos todo por la borda
a todos les descontaban lo que hago
soy emprendedor soy abogado emprendedor
desde hace ya cuatro años me dedico un
emprendimiento personal de panadería y
pastelería voy a decir cuál es para que
no graven que estoy haciendo publicidad
y nosotros en panadería y pastelería es
paula somos muy preocupados de todas
esas cosas
y cuando decido dedicarme a emprender
la gente pensaba que yo estaba loco
bueno todavía siento cuando decido salir
me la vega un estudio jurídico
también se presta más encima panadería y
pastelería que es un rubro como complejo
pero saben que yo tenía el propósito yo
no quería vender pan y pasteles
yo quería entregar momentos felices yo
quería adornar yo quería fomentar
instancias familiares estancias con
amigos una rica comida
quería fomentar el desarrollo de la
región
porque también esta charla tiene que ver
con cómo construimos la ciudad el mañana
y como decía en la charla anterior las
las ciudades el elemento más importante
las ciudades no son necesariamente sus
edificios son sus personas y si tenemos
personas como decía antes que esas le
ven que se las juegan que tienen ganas
por supuesto que se pueden salir
adelante
y me gusta también que a través del
modelo franquicia
hemos podido desarrollar y potenciar y
fomentar historias como las de jóvenes
que están por aquí
a fines de diciembre 2017 llega mi
oficina un personaje alto 50 50 y un año
9 lado
nervioso porque quería empezar a
trabajar con nosotros
dentro de las cosas que me cuentan es
que él vive en villa alemana trabajaba
en santiago iba todos los días a
santiago santiago nacional que consume
que consume mucho es cierto
y nosotros queremos que en valparaíso no
hay oportunidades llega hablar conmigo y
una de las cosas que me cuenta es que
bueno lo echaron de su trabajo y está
buscando oportunidades de emprender
dentro de las cosas que me cuenta
también es que tenía la presión sobre
los 150 yo no entiendo mucho de eso ya
pero según él era sobre todo los límites
y el doctor le había dicho que si se
tomaba todos los remedios y así algo que
el doctor decía o sea comía lo que tenía
que comer tomar lo que tenía que tomar
que se tomaba los remedios a la hora
adecuada
con suerte iba a llegar a los 140 de
presión excepto hoy en día siete ocho
meses más tarde
más tarde de que abrió para el abrió en
marzo
trabaja con su familia
su señora y su hijo lo ayudan está
emprendiendo
ya no está pensando en chuta no tengo
oportunidades sino que está pensando en
abrir más locales en buscar más
oportunidades
se le ve contento
dejo de tomar los remedios para la
presión
y la presión oscila entre los 120 y los
130 que según él era absolutamente
impensado hace un año atrás
barreras y oportunidades también
les cuento que el emprendimiento no es
todo miel sobre ojuelas les cuento que
esta cuestión no es tan fácil como uno
como no se lo pintan esto es difícil yo
también he fracasado y me ha costado
y me ha dolido también porque cuando te
va mal pensando te lo dije
para quien lo hicistes y no era
necesario te gusta andar teniendo
problemas etcétera
pero cuando uno está complicado
cuando uno está
con
la moral baja
uno tiene dos opciones comenzó a morir
tiene todo por la borda o cuando hay un
propósito cuando hay algo que uno
efectivamente quiere y cuando uno no
quiere ser una lechuga cuando uno quiere
decir decidir definir y ser arquitecto y
constructor de su propio futuro y
destino tiene la opción de levantarse y
levantarse de schalke con el aprendizaje
de los errores que ha cometido si sabe
lo que hago yo cuando estaba complicado
y cuando estaba un solo y cuando mayor
mal
en tierra
pongo la canción de rocky
[Música]
mi radio antigua presa sí
empieza
para más
[Aplausos]
ah
la paz
[Música]
y me doy ánimo y pienso en que no tengo
que ser una lechuga y pienso saben que
en el propósito y pienso saben que
pienso en esa historia de las ranitas
que ustedes les tiene que haber llegado
por whatsapp en algún minuto esas
cadenas que mandan y esperando ranitas
que se caen en un balde de leche
resulta que
empieza la batalla del papel del hotel
ya llevan más de 20 horas para peleando
y una de ellas dos se cansa y le dicen
otras seis que yo no doy más pero sí
inicial que nos va a salvar algo va a
pasar no quiero hay más
deja pasar y se muere
y la otra mitad sigue sigue y sigue
por estas cosas de la física la química
o lo que sea
la leche se empieza a convertir la
mantequilla se empieza a solidificar
y después de 30 o 40 horas para talento
logré tener una base
y pegue el salto y sale adelante
y se adelante obviamente gracias
a que se la jugó
otro tema que me gustaría tocar aquí
tiene que ver con el foco con la
finalidad de cada ser humano porque
además el ser humano no logra
necesariamente aquello para lo que es
bueno
no logra necesariamente aquello que le
gusta saben lo que logra el ser humano
y aquello en lo que se enfoca
si no nos enfocamos
no llegan
y parte de las cosas en las que nos
tenemos que enfocar tiene que ver con el
propósito de nuestras vidas que
realmente se nos olvida si esto la
finalidad de todo ser humano es ser
feliz y realmente los que somos medios
locos y estamos en los proyectos y nos
enamoramos de los proyectos pensamos
hablar del proyecto hablar del proyecto
pensamos el proyecto respirar el viento
dormimos del proyecto y nos empezamos a
desenfocar y resulta que esto es una
mesa que tiene distintas patas excepto y
algunas de estas patas
se conectan
con lo que son los pilares que nosotros
necesitamos para ser feliz y saben que
tengo que confesarles que a mí me ha
pasado que me desenfocado y por eso se
los quiero comentar
me ha pasado que han llegado amigos han
dicho 6 que
siento que te perdimos
o familiares que dicen shayk
siento que estoy en otras ya no eres el
mismo de antes y eso es súper importante
que lo tengamos presente presente para
que no nos olvidemos que esto es una
mesa que tienen distintos pilares y
tenemos que enfocarnos principalmente en
ser feliz tengamos proyecto o no
atrevámonos es una es un llamado súper
importante sepamos quién como dice la
charla barrera sí pero oportunidades
también
pero sin perder el foco de ser feliz uno
de mis propósitos no es vender el pan
19 el propósito es alimentar la región
ojalá a futuro alimentar chile
ojalá también no solamente vender pan
sino que regalar y entregar el momento
felices hoy día somos una empresa que
partiendo bien desde abajo tenemos 90
personas que trabajamos hay 90 familias
que dependen de la familia paula esto
y lo hacemos con propósito
lo hacemos con ganas y lo hacemos
convencidos
y saben cuál es mi propósito
parte de mi propósito o el propósito más
importante
se llama frank
se llama santino
se llama bautista y son estos tres
bichitos que están ahí bueno estos son
mis hijos y además de esta foto esta
foto tiene algo particular porque yo soy
amante de los caballos y amante del
campo y los saco todos los fin de semana
a pasear y en la semana también y me
entretengo y lo paso bien y lo estoy
formando
nunca tenemos que perder el foco nunca
tenemos que olvidar
y ser felices les quiero contar una
historia
éstos eran esto eran tres personas 55
años más o menos pongamos el contexto
norte de chile piedras arena sol sin que
me dé la tarde
1 2 y 3 una pala y un épico 6 a 0 0 y le
pregunté qué está haciendo
en este empuje efe estoy cansado poner
la espalda está haciendo aquí hemos
pegando vida y por qué porque es lo
único que es hacer nosotros es nada más
acerca del segundo
y usted está haciendo
aquí estoy pegando bien a la mente ha
alcanzado 80 mente aspirado
picando piedras porque porque me vengan
con esto salgo me pagan me tomo una
cervecita
se acerca tercero y usted que está
haciendo aquí estoy construyendo una
catedral pero como si estoy cansado hay
sol hace calor
pero las piedras que estoy extrayendo se
va a construir la primera catedral de mi
psuv
y yo soy parte de eso
y sabe que existe
con mi trabajo no me pagan mucho
estoy pagándole los estudios a mi hijo
orgullosamente para mí a mi familia es
el primer profesional de toda mi
historia familiar y de toda la historia
familiar que me enseñaron
ya bien el llamado también el invitación
a ustedes
qué tiene que decidir optar por las
barreras como la oportunidad sabiendo
que hay barreras
tienen que construir oportunidades a
ustedes que tienen hambre y ganas de
construir la ciudad del futuro
pueden decidir que quieren ser
quiero hacer una lechuga o quiero ser
arquitecto y constructor del futuro
quiero ser samuel pierre por langley o
quiero ser los hermanos wright
quiero ser la ranita que dejó de
patalear y se murió o la ranita que
siguió batallando pataleando batallando
es a salvo
quiero ubicar piedra
o construir catedrales
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah